reject nation we're watching the next
episode of brooklyn nine nine leave a
like if you can also uh thanks to the
boys of prepper for helping to set it
down these highlights full length watch
alongs where you sync up with this stuff
is over at our patreon thanks to all who
have joined us your support means a lot
speakers almost fell over let's do this
[Music]
take a picture give him one second this
light is really unflattering for his
complexion it doesn't have to be perfect
tom olsen is a bad dude he's held up
four electronic stores at gunpoint and i
wish you hadn't read that annie
leibowitz book
[Laughter]
it's in color instead of black and white
shouts out to annie leibowitz black and
white
black and white is crate man it's so
artistic
nypd
carfoot chase my birthday wish finally
came true
there is no reason for jake to run on
top of the cars
just kept looking at next to the car so
like you would have way more chances of
catching up with him if you just ran on
the actual street yeah then like grabbed
his leg back
oh nice pimp blocks pam i was like
you're pampering play
uh you sure you should be here today
jake you wiped out hard it wasn't so
much a wipeout as it was a controlled
powerful search wow
[Laughter]
haven't been to the doctor in 11 years
how trill is that your tone's braggy but
your words are real sad did it clear you
for active duty first of all the doctor
was a woman there's a such thing as
women doctors sarge i lied for effect it
was a man
did he clear you or not
he did not all right let's get to work
guys we got a perp to catch uh forget
that uh uh no look oh no sarge i know
this case better than anyone and i am
this close to solving it your fingers
are really far apart yeah i also have a
hairline fracture in my thumb mankind's
least important finger am i right
please please please please just let me
stay on the case all right i promise i
won't go into the field or do anything
dangerous fine you can work the case
from right here but you are tied to your
desk
tied to my desk mr gray will see you now
sarge
kevin insists on you and marcus joining
us for dinner at our house we agree to
keep our personal and professional lives
separate it is weird enough i am dating
your nephew without dragging your
husband and dog into it
i can say i'm sick well i've used a sick
excuse for you eight times i think
they're catching on you can say you're
sick no one would ever believe that no
i'm inviting some
intimacy buffers
dinner party at your house
oh
mama oh yeah
you're the furniture out of your living
room so i can showcase some on my new
dance opera why do some of it do the
whole thing yes nothing would make me
happier
there's a slight chance that in the past
i may have tried a little too hard
around the captain so this time i'm
gonna be super chill good plan it just
says you got uninvited what oh honey
yeah have you seen jay
no i was out getting him some healing
broth i was torn between chicken or beef
but then it hit me
goat
it looks to me like you did something
stupid
like try to lift a heavy box sarch come
on in my condition
[Music]
[Laughter]
go home and get better now all right
fine but i'm taking this box of evidence
with me if you can pick it up you can
take it deal
oh yeah
oh yeah
what are you doing here swinging by to
pick up charles and then we're headed to
sunny beachy only recently devastated by
financial crisis atlantic city
official trip nicknamed acdc atlantic
city dudes club
one of the room service options is a
carving station talking prime rib in bed
and what's this that's expensive it
sounds like you guys are gonna have fun
oh oh we will cause we're staying at the
ravanna
jake this is not the ravenna no it is
not but it is the world famous sea fam
motel it's not a vacation
it's a stakeout my perp has a brother
who lives in this dump and i think he's
hiding out with him here i can't believe
you lied to me it wasn't a lie
it was
an aloof
i can't let olsen walk and i can't catch
him alone plus this is gonna be super
fun new trip nickname ac dc atlantic
city detectives club oh okay fine ooh
good one there he is no arm rib arm rib
shoulder
marcus detective diaz what a surprise i
didn't expect you for another nine and a
half minutes
rude to be early well let's cancel the
entire evening
we only have to make small talk for
eight minutes and 45 seconds we better
keep it in personal acceptable topics
include
the birth of the transistor we only have
to fill eight minutes sure but think
about it as 480 seconds and you'll see
why i'm concerned
i'm converting everything into seconds
from now on something stinks and it's
definitely the food you brought it's my
mom's famous nisswa salad amy all your
cooking stinks why would you even get
involved with tuna and egg
we really really mind just throw it out
i will not throw it out but i will open
the window because i'm a nice person
oh no
and i'm an even nicer person
that was mean a bit anticlimactic
do you desire a crisp and potato ah
don't mind if i double wait a minute
crispin potato why are you fancy talking
how dare you sir i speak the common
tongue
you only do that when you're lying or
hiding something hiding
pish-posh hey
sergeant don't hey sarge me peralta i'm
about to break the rest of your damn
body okay fine just take a picture of my
penis first for posterity and then do
what you must
much nicer just the four of us we can
really get into it yeah let's do just
that uh so marcus
what uh orchids can you name oh that's
easy none
[Laughter]
blacks the podium evotella raymond do
you know how much i love hearing you
talk about orchids great then there's
ariex but
i would love to hear more about our
guest
no tell us about your family i have one
oh you've got to give him more detail
than that her father's a teacher they're
from benson nurse speaking of which have
they finished repairing the hubble space
telescope yes six years ago
do you have siblings
i have
two sisters
i have to leave this
oh no no rosa no that was way too
personal no one needs to know you have
sisters
new topic
the moons of jupiter i think i might be
pregnant ah oh
oh
[Laughter]
the fact that you would sell me out
after i brought you to atlantic city on
a half expenses paid best friends trip i
know i'm sorry it's just
i was worried about you getting hurt no
charles don't apologize we're mad at him
[Laughter]
you're on timeout it's your timeout
chair fine but first i have to go to the
bathroom and it will be work due to my
injured tailbone and bruised black
good luck buddy
what the hell
please be olson please be olson please
be all sin
you're not olsen
hey guys
what the hell are you doing out there
peralta
would you believe that my urine stream
was so powerful that nope
[Laughter]
you have lost the right to pee
you can fidget little man
it's gonna be on you and we're all
covered in with
[Laughter]
bosoms tender ah i'm gonna pretend that
you didn't just ask me that are your
senses
heightened i think i might be pregnant
not bitten by a radioactive spider
it senses i didn't
i've been feeling run down lately my
stomach's been weird i just did the math
in my head and i think i'm a little bit
late late to uh
oh right right you're um
what if i'm pregnant do i tell marcus
what do i do with a baby how do you take
care of those things why are their heads
so soft
take a pregnancy test you're stressed
smart immediately you got anxiety i
hired you as jakel's the clown how'd
that go and jeremy the giraffe has a
very long neck
that's it
[Laughter]
i am right all the time there's our
purpose
jay
observe him from a safe distance while
we wait for the atlantic city pd to show
up my exact instinct as well sir
oh no are you certain we have to cut the
party short uh yes unfortunately
detective diaz has an unexpected
emergency to take care of all right do
you need to go as well no it's not quite
captain worthy
still advanced enough
are best qualified to handle the
um non-emergency emergency yes precisely
see she's great
hey what's up hi
sorry we're so late actually the party
is over what
you know what my friend it's time to be
chill for real
yep chill
yes that's the spirit
one drink amy he's looking at us pretend
to use the ice machine boyle gladly
why is it so fun to get hotel ice it
feels wasteful but also like i bought
this room i deserve this heist i feel
you chuck
damn it stay put peralta i will don't
worry i'm just gonna let sarge follow
him i'm gonna stay right here i can't do
it i'm gonna cut him off in the alley
ah shortcut you just got changed
whoa
oh
oh jake
oh
the worst part is olson got away that's
the worst part
you could have died man i wasn't hurt
that badly the doctor said all my
bleeding was internal that's where the
blood's supposed to be
friend doesn't want my help because he
insists on being an idiot you know what
you're lost cause i'm down trying to
help you terry's leaving
what people got hurt because of me perps
get away people get hurt that's part of
the job but if you don't give yourself a
break you'll be no use to anyone
because you'll be dead
real talk alert
i mean
wrong
body has the structural integrity of a
chocolate souffle
good hug
did we steal these sunglasses last night
no
you paid the bodega guy 200.
well let's put a makeup dinner in the
calendar uh
i don't give a word too much
i mean that would be great thank you sir
oh
i'm not pregnant
i'd say i just wanted to say thank you
i'm glad i could help
now let's never talk about
stop pointing at it
and how's your broken everything doctor
gave me the all clear to come back to
work and i'm allowed to have light
non-strenuous sex provided i stretch
before and after
nice
decided to take two more vacation days a
friend of mine said i needed to
experience life outside of work smart
friend anyways i figured i would boil a
legit trip to ac so that's right y'all
ah
zoot suit boil this is gonna be epic bro
quick sarge punch me in the ribs as hard
as you can
ah
take your vacay jake
you're dead
the floor is lava
another hilarious installment of
brooklyn nine-nine with the with the
sage little nuggets
of life advice
for those who cannot ever stop working
uh yeah this is really fun i had a blast
i uh i've been to many an awkward dinner
party and i've never been able to get
out with just like uh you know uh i
wouldn't be the type to make up a crazy
lie i would be so paranoid about like
you know deceiving my my close people so
you know i've never bailed on a dinner
party that way
never made a nicoise salad
uh i haven't broken that many bones in
my life so uh you know those things
caused me to reflect on my own
experiences throughout this episode and
realize that i have so much more life to
live and so many more things to explore
uh yeah you know but i really felt for
for jake you know his tenacity is
inspiring and the way that he was
constantly trying to play through the
pain never acknowledging
what was causing him
you know anguish stress
physical immobility impairment it's
really inspiring to watch him still
pursue the perp
and get himself even more injured in the
process you know sometimes you have to
double down in order to get results
what do you think greg
i think that you are the worst person to
go to a dinner with
i think if you ride passenger with john
or bring john with you it'll be forever
until you leave
yeah there's no way it's could work
i would
there's no way you can a halt
or
stephanie beatrice your way out of a
situation
most of the time is why are we still
here
i'm in the car already
where's john
i i enjoy people
you don't know how to leave
yeah yeah that's fair
i gotta gotta learn that there's there's
something there's something weird
internally last one remaining all the
time mm-hmm
i and a friend who put that on an rsvp
the party ends at this time or whenever
john leaves
and that's that's a real
rsvp i could probably dig up for you
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what that is i don't know where that
comes from i i'll unpack it and i'll
report back on next week's episode as to
uh
as to why what feels off about
and then he comes over here and he's
like i have a hard time with time
management
it starts with little things
when i'm with people and especially the
further the further on into life you get
like you know moments with people are
precious and you don't get as many
opportunities for them
this is a recent problem no when was
that invitation a year ago
that was i haven't been to a party in
three years
now
no this is not a problem any longer
i know you i've been down through
hangouts of course and if it's not at
the party i don't hang out with anybody
it's not that's not everything at all
and it's not at the party if it's not it
is and when i do see people nowadays i'm
like i have to make this an hour or
maybe two hours because i gotta go after
this like
i could think of as many instances
already
where if it's not inside anymore he's
out in the parking lot standing by the
car and he's talking there for like an
hour to do it had that many
opportunities since the pandemic struck
since 2020 began i haven't had that many
opportunities yeah do you still have
donors and you've done it plenty before
then
absolutely before then sure yeah i i've
had people like aaron even tell me
hanging out with jts or whatever
we should mention jt
he's a he's a pervert and he's a pervert
yeah jt is a pervert yeah it's a good
thing that uh we don't linger too long
at jt he might start grabbing us jg is a
massive burger it's so horny he's so
horny just won't stop
i don't want to watch pornography on
your projector
the pornography is always of him i know
and no one else that's like like jump we
gotta leave for you why are you still
talking to jt
i'm uncomfortable
you know yeah i was like well i don't go
out enough anymore because of the bad
day
i didn't say i don't go out enough i'm
just saying i don't find myself in that
predicament any longer
i don't have opportunities to be
okay mark my words
how would i know it's not like you
invite me anywhere anyway
anyway i i gotta get that's a crowd
another chronic john life problem i've
never been good at inviting people
places i've never i've had multiple
people say why don't you invite me
anywhere i'm like oh yes
i'm so accustomed to having way too many
things to choose between that to be in a
position to like
author and experience and pull someone
into it is a bit like whoa
it's okay i just say no
hey you have a much easier time i
wouldn't want to be there forever
fair well if i drive separately
yeah that makes sense for me
i i yeah i like to to
i i like a night that goes and and
twists and turns and is an adventure if
people are getting sick of me that's
shitty and i should leave but uh but
yeah
i i like uh
an expanded experience
yeah
just saying all the times you know you
got stuff to do the next day
that's what i'd say now
[Laughter]
we can't talk about the show what's her
to talk about it's [ __ ] funny funny
yeah really enjoyable funny i think the
amy and gina storyline was uh weirdly
underwritten and not that punchy and uh
that was a little lackluster i i didn't
find it particularly funny and i was
like what is up with this this is
something feels really off about the
punchiness of the comedy here um feels
half cooked
half a bait and but uh the other story
lines are funny and uh yeah i like how
cannon made you laugh
you got one joke yeah
yeah [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you nick cannon
i still think he's not a character he's
not really he's not this whole episode
as you
as they verge
they go into the next room he's not a
character
i like the resolution for amy and gina
but i i i agree that's that was an
undercooked
it's just way more colorful with jake
and boyle and everything
yeah yeah
and terry some good terry this episode i
like authoritative terry
i know right right what spots yeah what
or if we're walking somewhere as a group
john will take photos
and he doesn't tell people so then what
because i'll just run and catch up to
you
you
try to communicate every every time with
you there's always people everyone's
like where's john
oh let's stop and walk let's let's stop
and wait for john
that's like just once in your life just
be like hey i want to take a photo of
this thing
instead of all of us
wait where's john
i never say it i always just go let's
just keep walking
i'm the only one who's not considerate
of greece
let's just go but the rest of the girl's
like no i feel bad let's just stay i'm
used to just going and catching up with
people and so yeah
we're subversive but now olivia and i
are always like just just just keep
moving he's going to do that just keep
moving don't worry about it no no it's
rude let's wait for john
dude it's not rude if you're if you if
ever you were saying that for my
consideration i don't mind i'll take his
hand i'm just going to take a quick
picture i'll catch up with you guys i
understand
that my weird predilection for frequent
picture taking how weird people do it
all you gotta do is say five seconds
i'm gonna take a photo all right i'll
catch up with you guys yeah that's fair
i'm gonna take a photo okay
time me on this okay
i'm gonna take a photo i'll catch up
with you guys that's less than five
seconds
yeah
instead of
where's john
no let's just stop and wait for
various
there he is
ugh
this is doing wonders for my ability to
look at myself you know we don't go
anywhere anymore man so it's fun i know
i don't have this i i just i yeah now
when i feel compelled to take pictures i
look around and realize i'm all alone
yeah
the way it should be
ah yeah it's easier that way
life's way easier when there's nobody
around
yeah [ __ ] people mm-hmm that's why i
leave early
sayonara people as much anxiety as
people give me i do i don't know i love
people i like
i don't interacting and i like
realize what therapy's taught me is
people suck
they can yeah and i'm the only good
thing out there you are
facts
we should all be so lucky
to have
you to run after
i go no let him
let him chase me hunt us down
they'll always keep coming
as long as i'm greg freaking out
[Laughter]
someday we'll balance out into the
middle
there's no bounce i'm just a really
blunt like i gotta go yeah you're the
kind of guy that one [ __ ] like you're
gonna say bye at a party those buys are
like okay john's gonna have like 30 more
conversations as these are by like i'm
saying bye and then that turns into a
conversation and then that turns into a
conversation so that's why i'm like
we're not writing with john we're
writing separately yeah
it's not my problem i just say that's
why i don't ride with you that's fair i
don't care what you do let's make that
clear
i don't care if you stay
as long as you want i just don't like to
ride with you because of that but if
we're not riding together you stay as
long as you want i could give two shits
so i'm going to a party now good
just riding separately
i'm glad they did
i'll see
you can leave in an hour and i'll even
through it yeah
um anyway
but come on what do i do
come on come on i can take it
come on
you already laid it out what do i do i
don't know if you do anything raw i mean
you're very plenty wrong you're very
organized and i stopped you're on top of
time don't play the victim tell me
what's going on here
uh you know i mean you know you're very
adherent to your schedule so once that
hour's up it's time to go you know like
and uh hey that's it's that's not really
a thing that you can only pose as being
a bad thing you know oh come on i do
plenty wrong you gotta point out one
thing i do wrong or it's annoying
if you ride with me
[Music]
if i one thing that you do wrong if i'm
riding with
you not wrong i'm not saying you
sticking around wrong
one thing that can become cumbersome or
annoying when riding with you if you're
not
or like yeah you're uh you're my
i bring you with me or come on was what
is it what is it that i do
i can take it
um come on there's gotta be something
a hug
[Music]
i don't i don't i don't
i don't know really i mean there's
something you're doing that's like
annoying
don't think i know what fun is to write
together and i want to go
but the actual attending of it is not
there's nothing wrong with that yeah
yeah yeah
come on
give it to me
is that i leave too soon
when you want to stick around
well sure i mean we found it
but that was obvious from the game
that was that's the most obvious
conclusion possible is i would like to
stay longer but i rode with you so we're
leaving now that's why we can't go
anywhere together
one day though we'll find a party where
we're both like i am ready to leave
right me too all right we're out let's
go and then that will be the day we'll
have and then we'll have like a very
silent car right back what i can't
figure out still
is sometimes
we leave here
to go to the same location
and you usually leave before me
and somehow you still arrive
after me
one time i stopped at a kinkos
that explains every time
that's right
the curse of ginkgos has long lasted
that's right man
that's a good that's a good point yeah i
mean well
maybe it's because i was using a
different gps as possible
maybe says i drive like a madman
i mean i i relish in driving where
whereas i know you hate to drive so you
hate being on the road so i don't hate
driving you hating in traffic which i
also hate is fair
driving in crappy traffic sucks uh
yeah i'm like the good traffic
that's sure the plus and traffic well
there are times where if it's not moving
like a full speed but it's still moving
i don't care so much if it's like we're
we're stopping and we're going and we're
stopping and we're going and i'm just
sitting
you know like that gets pretty boring
it's about the motion it's about the
motion you can keep in perpetual motion
that feels moderately too pretty fast i
can meet you there you know
where is it i gotta feed the cats man
yeah we can leave i'm not trying to
figure out these parties
we can leave this party yeah we gotta go
man jesus christ you're taking forever
yeah yeah
i don't want to leave man this is my
only social interactions for the
pandemic is here in this room
oh yeah
that's not fair i've hung out with
people like four times in the past
two years so
he's down playing i know he's hung up
way more people than that
six times so foolish went to erica's
birthday i invited you out to several
times
yeah christmas party i know you see
people i'm so full of [ __ ]
i know i i have and i do but not very
often not like it's not a weekly
occurrence that i would be hanging out
with somebody
yeah
i prefer not to i'll stay home and catch
up on television on the weekend or right
yeah
and in some ways the pandemic has made
things easier
but what it hasn't made easier is ending
this review
oh no i'm jon too oh
i haven't managed to leave you caught it
oh god i caught the bug but do you want
to leave that's the key that's the
question
yeah
now i wanna okay i'm ready to go all
right
i'm ready to go
the 18 000 people who did not make it to
this part of the video
if you made it
comment
[Music]